welcome to this video I'm playing Adele
move here from France yeah going for a
four for a change okay I get g6 mmm yeah
I'm just going for the maroc see why not
guy is playing one of the main lines
there for black the so-called googan
it's a system named after booty Gorgon
it sir I think a Georgian Grandmaster
back then Soviet of course but from
Georgia so a five thank you think this
is the right move but I'm not totally
sure
just wanted to prevent a form them
intending to play be 393 back this kind
of thing it's just a bit slower she had
this Ruby one not sure about it k goes
b6 that's actually good news it takes
away some flexibility on the black side
okay so he actually is attacking my
center like I just thought that it could
happen okay I'm where am I going to do
one or 2 c1 probably 2 g1 and some this
makes it more difficult for him to move
any of his pawns yeah the f5 idea is
interesting in the maroc see point um
it's it's weakening in some way because
like look at those pawns like in 76
square e 6 is weakish but he black is
activating also AI has look on a fade
springs to life those positions are
often surprisingly tricky from a
technical point of view it initial
thought is that why it must be a much
much better but it's not it's not that
clear sometimes we will see what what is
going to do my ideas just to go like
castles maybe bishop age six trading
office bishop rookie one trying to put
pressure on the central files and it's a
slowish build up kind of thing black is
some a little bit deprived of clear
active pawn breaks but quite sure it's
taking very long which is not is not
disconnected
I wonder what is so intention is with
this long thing and we had it's not an
easy to play position but still it's a
very long thing you would expect some I
don't know 27 or normal normal ish
looking weird am I disconnected
sometimes it happens that no everything
looks ok and now is yeah he's going if
we five yeah yeah I was thinking that
this could be an idea I mean ok these
successes is hanging in if I take it I
mean it's probably it's going to play
you for that much is clear and then c 3
is hanging with check but i can play
like 95 it's got a queen edge form I
mean one thing is if I just castle him
how is he what is he doing with this
pawn I mean I'm taking it next move
basically or later let's say rook f6 I
have Bishop to g5 which wins the
exchange
well I mean I wasn't told to show maybe
I could have taken on d6 but this is
still a very convenient position okay if
I go before he wants to go night is six
and then 94 kind of been tactically
tricky okay before I can have this
awesome 94 I'm just taking now and d6
still hanging after 2694 its bits I know
like at some activity and I'm not sure
that it's necessary to give them that
will not be 5 i'm preventing 94 and the
other thing that is certainly going to
be a factor is the time a second thing
is g for traps the bishop which is so
kind of isn't this now possible i mean
i'm just winning that Bishop there or
not how is he not losing it i don't see
it no okay exhibition I could have done
that earlier right instead of 9 p-5 but
ok
nah got to take the dog okay didn't miss
much black resigns yeah well I kind of a
disastrous game yeah so this time I
didn't got a package this time I took
one for one of my neighbors so they just
collected it so let's have a look em
here this is an interesting line that
the 5 line I am I'm not completely sure
what's the current state of theory is
blacks ideas if I go like this there is
owned a form and possibly Queenie 5 i'm
not sure about that if i want that this
is why i went here i think this is a
less precise version of something that
Kara wanna played against cars in 2014
in the sink filled cup I think in in in
that case caruana was it was a little
bit different Bishop was still don't
have one thing on not not quite sure but
okay 97 I think this is all fairly
normal and certainly no worm no big
issue anything for black f5 is
interesting that that's an active way to
play it as i said already during the
game at some time during the game it's
interesting to play like that getting
some activity going now here he took
like almost two minutes to play that
movie 5 mmm yeah i think it's that's if
it's probably just not working if i take
it efore I wasn't totally sure yeah my
my night is hanging with check and it's
it's kind of complicated this thing the
computer okay the compounds to take
check and then go here let's make some
sense check and this is appalled and the
bishop pair which is nice okay yeah but
computer also gives this as a clear
advantage so my move wasn't bad was a
good pragmatic choice probably a form b
form yeah and now i can play g4 of
course IAM i was i was a bit too quick i
mean i was i was seeing that 95 is great
and i didn't really look for other moves
completely violating the candidate move
principle okay it's blitz chess but
anyway i could have could have seen it
but ok black is still in a bed very bad
way here the relatively best according
to the engine is like night f for
something and this is like minus two so
yet after that g4 I finally finally saw
it yeah yeah the maroc see by this is
one of my favorite setups with with
whites always nice to have I never lost
the game with it in tournament chess and
I won a ton so something that I always
welcome to have okay well thanks for
watching